[Music]
Hello everybody. First things first, I
actually have to apologize. I uh I was
coming into the fair today. I was coming
up the escalator to registration because
this is my first day at the fair. came
for my talk and I saw for the first time
this big banner that's said at AI
World's Fair. It's like a place for
builders, not yappers. And I was a
builder once, but I'm definitely a
yapper now. Um, so so bear with me, but
I think we'll have fun. Um, on that
note, I don't love yapping by myself. I
love yapping with others. And it is the
last afternoon, the last day, but there
is an interactive component to this
presentation. So at times I will present
slides that look like this.
You don't have to clap, but you do have
to say the words with me as they appear.
So, in this case, what we would say is
excellent. Thank you. I knew you could
do it. One more practice one.
Okay, great. Excellent. I hear you. So,
my name is Sam. I am a principal forward
deployed or deployed engineer at
Windsurf. Um, and in the spirit of this
talk, getting to know Windsor and
Windsurf getting to know you. You should
get to know me, right? So, here are some
facts about me and my life. I work at
Windsurf. I love Slack emojis if you
couldn't tell by the first slide. I
sometimes wear turtlenecks as evidenced
in this photo. I have been known to
exaggerate my title. I'm not actually a
principal deployed engineer, just
deployed engineer for now. Um, and I am
speaking at the AI Worlds Fair.
It's a little lackluster, right? Hence
the neutral emoji. Do you feel like you
really got to know me based on these
simple facts?
No, I don't think so either. I wouldn't
expect you to. Let's do this. Let's see
what we can infer from these otherwise
superficial observations
to see if we can get to know me a little
better. Right? And for fun, let's put a
little framing on it. Let's change this
fun neutral face to a little the little
purple devil emoji,
right? and see what these facts say
about me. Maybe I am the kind of person
who brags about, you know, working in
the valley, right? Maybe I prioritize
Slack over real work and that's why I
love Slack emojis. Maybe I wear
turtlenecks because I think I have a
superior fashion sense, right? Maybe I
exaggerate my title because I'm power
hungry. Maybe I'm speaking here because
I enjoy the sound of my own voice.
Right? And we can do we can do the
inverse, too, right? Let's turn this
little devil into into an angel. Right?
Maybe I work hard and that's why I work
at Windsurf. Maybe I like Slack because
I value team building. Still in the
superior fashion sense. I think that
one's fair. U maybe I'm indifferent
towards titles, right? And maybe I'm
speaking here because I like sharing
things with friends. Sharing things with
friends, I should say. Either way, we
took some otherwise superficial
conspicuous observations and we turned
them with some framing into something
that actually says something about me
and says something about my behavior.
Right? What we really need now would be
some hard evidence. Right? So I see two
of my colleagues over here. If they came
up and you know as trusted sources told
you guys that I spend all day on Slack,
then maybe that evidence combined with
the visible evidence here would lead you
to believe that I spend most of my day
on Slack, which I won't confirm nor deny
at this point, right?
We'll come back to this. Um I can
imagine what you're thinking. Here's one
of those slides.
Okay, great. So, in the spirit of
getting to know you, let's talk about
Windinsurf a little bit. Raise your hand
if you've heard of Windsurf.
Okay, great. Raise your hand or keep
your hand raised if you've used
Windsurf.
Awesome. So, for those who are not
familiar or as a refresher to all of
you, we are we offer an AI coding
toolkit, right? And we package it in a
couple different ways. One is through
the Windsurf editor, right, which looks
similar to what Augment just showed. um
and also a windsurf plug-in that you can
use in a variety of idees. Right? The
core value prop of windsurf
is this. Anything you do in an editor,
you can do faster and you can do better.
Now, I could stand here and give you the
whole typical sales pitch, right? And I
could give you the windsurf overview and
I could give you windsurf's
differentiators and I could give you
windsurf's pace of innovation and I
could give you I don't even know who put
this one in there but the windsurf AI
stack right until you turn around and
you might even say something like
wait this talk was about winer this talk
was about context right I know what you
guys want so I'm I'm bringing it back
just bear with me
what we've established So far, even in
these funny introductions, are a couple
things. One, it's hard to know someone
based on surf surface level
observations. Two, you can make educated
guesses though through a variety of
heruristics.
Three, you can also make educated
guesses via hard evidence and you can
combine those two things. And four,
WinSurf helps you code. You'll have to
take my word for it. We have some free
promo codes at the booth afterwards.
Right. So that brings me to what I think
is the principal problem of the coding
AI space right now which is this. It is
not hard to generate code and it hasn't
been for a while.
Anybody in this room in a couple hours
or even less because of tools like
Windsurf and Augment, right,
can help you spin up a simple UI, wrap
around some Premier model, take some
user prompt and and spit back an answer,
right? It is not hard to generate code.
However, it is hard to generate code for
you.
Not because any of you are particular,
you know, troublemakers. Maybe you are,
but it's hard to generate code that fits
into an existing large codebase.
Adheres to organizational policies or
standards, adheres to personal
preferences. Everybody has their own way
they like to code, right? And is future
proof. I'm not sure what I meant when I
wrote this one on the slide 30 minutes
ago, but I let's skip that one. Right?
In short, right? What makes
it feel so magical when you're using
Windsurf and you accept a suggestion
that feels like we're inside your head
or when our agent Cascade recommends you
do something in a certain way and you
say, "That's exactly what I was
thinking. That's exactly how I think
about it."
The answer is context.
And there are two major pillars
underpinning our context philosophy at
Windsurf.
what context
and how much. And I'm going to break
both of these down for you. So the what
when we talk about context, what context
are we talking about? Well, I like to
think of it in two big buckets, right?
The first bucket is heruristics and the
second bucket is hard evidence. Like we
spoke about in my intro,
the first bucket is your behavior and
what you do and what you are trying to
do. The second bucket is your
environment and the world around you.
So things in the first bucket look like
code above and below your cursor, open
files, files you've opened and then
closed in what order, what's ready,
what's pasted on your clipboard, copied
to your clipboard, excuse me. Um, you
know, what's what's in your terminal?
What have you been doing? What are you
trying to do? How are you acting in this
IDE?
And the second bucket, the hard evidence
is stuff like code, documentation, rules
that you provide, memories that the
agent generates about you, right? More
code, lots and lots of code and whatever
else is in your repo, right? So, it's
two big buckets. It's user state
and it's state of your codebase.
And that ultimately brings us to sort of
the magic formula, right? What is
relevant output when it comes to coding
agents?
It's your prompt plus the state of your
codebase
plus the user state.
And this is part of the reason, right?
There's secret sauce in here, but this
is part of the reason that it feels so
cool when Whis generates something for
you. So, the second big pillar is how
much.
Now, for a while, a lot of people were
focused on making context windows bigger
and bigger. Let's just shove more
context into this LLM call and it'll get
better. And for a while, that was true,
right? It continues to be true to an
extent. But since day one, we have found
much better results by optimizing for
what context gets put into that window
instead of just trying to make it
bigger. And that also helps solve the
issue of latency which is not just a
preference thing but a a core feature of
good AI coding agents.
Right? So
that brings us to the problem of finding
relevant context. It is hard to find
relevant context.
It has gotten easier. Every product does
it right? But as your codebase grows,
it remains hard because it's hard to
find relevant context quickly.
And that is something that we in Windsor
that we at Windsurf excel at because of
our background in GPU optimization. We
actually started as a company called
Exaf Function. So you can go look at
this little history lesson on your own,
right? We do this well, bluntly, we do
this very well, right? And and not only
do we have stuff going on behind the
scenes, but we build connectors for you
to be able to do this at your level, at
the user level, right? We have embedding
search, memories, rules, custom
workspaces, app mentions, plain text
search, knowledge base, multimodal
input, rip tide, MCP, remote indexing,
reranking, a parsing. Some of these are
more relevant than others. Some of these
make sense, some don't. Some are
tangential, some aren't, right? But
ultimately, we do this very well.
So I missed a slide there.
So ultimately, you know, this should
give you a better picture of how we
think about context at Windsurf. We
think about it in two ways. What context
and how much.
And the problem is not necessarily
giving LLMs more and more context, but
giving it more relevant context as it
relates to your user state and as it
relates to the state of your codebase,
right? And this is why when you use
Windsurf,
you begin to ask yourself questions
like, "Oh my god, does Windsorf really
know me? Have we met Windsurf?" You
might even say stuff like,
"Great." Hopefully somebody got that as
a sound bite and we can reuse it
internally.
That is what I wanted to talk about
today. I have no idea how many minutes
that was. I'm happy to take questions.
Um, also while Windsorf does get to know
you, you don't necessarily get to know
Winsurf back because it is a computer
program. Maybe some of you have opinions
on relationships with machines, but in
general, I don't know if you can know
them back. However, you are very much
able to get to know each and every
member, not each and every some members
of the Windsurf team such as the ones
here today. Um, so I know we're wrapping
up, but if you want to come by the
booth, I will be there. Other members of
Windsurf will be there. If you are a
developer looking for clarity on some of
the items, come by. If you are if you
work at a company and you want to get
Windsorf into your enterprise, come by.
We can talk as well. We love talking
about that.
But other than that, I will wrap uh I
will wrap up with questions unless
somebody has, you know, a better idea of
something to do.
Pull the room real quick. Go ahead.
Yes. Yes. So, um it is a variety of
huristics. Oh, that got everybody
leaving.
So I imagine when you are asking about
privacy
you mean the storage and training of
those things or
Yep.
Yep. So to be clear, we are only
processing information about you in your
editor, right? It's not like we have
access to your operating machine
obviously, right? And much like every
other LLM based tool that you interact
with, that information does leave and go
to our servers. However, our servers are
stateless. It is a pass through
transaction. We don't store any of your
data ever. We don't um train on any of
your data ever. So, if you're interested
in more of the, you know, security and
legal guarantees, definitely, you know,
come by or look on our website. Um, but
yeah, this is some of it.
[Music]